short films are kind of dead in the
water nowadays don't make a feature I
love the genre of short film even there
are more platforms now for it after film
school urged everyone to not waste plan
making short films it is a ridiculously
long road to get a feature film made and
out there on your first project do
something that that is not so ambitious
that you're not going to make it to the
finish line
my personal feeling is like short films
are kind of dead in the water nowadays
feature films nowadays your low-budget
features because you could do them on
such low budgets and cameras are so
accessible nowadays your low-budget
features are what your short films and
music videos were 20 years ago now you
don't hear about people doing a short or
like a music video and getting like a
huge budget film but if you're doing
your low-budget features on the
sentiment that those are to build up to
a big-budget feature that's that's
really kind of what it is nowadays they
look at what you've done you get a movie
that was a festival darling and that
gets you a bigger project and that might
have been the case years ago that
someone would look at a short film and
go like this is brilliant will now make
the future version of it but you can
count and those example examples exist
but you can count that on one hand I
think what you have to do today is you
have to make a feature as time-consuming
and as you know grueling is that is you
have to get that feature into a festival
and you have to get people to see it and
if possible win an award and that's the
moment that people will start paying
attention and will give you your next
project because they you have to try to
put yourself into their mindset they
have to justify why they hired you to
their bosses right so if you've made a
short film and you next want to do a
feature you need someone who is brave
and courageous enough to close that gap
for you and say I can justify to my boss
that on the basis of this short film I
gave you millions to do this feature and
I don't think there are enough brave
people out there whereas if you have
made a feature that has won an award
it's much easier for this guy to go like
well she has already made a feature that
won an award so I didn't take any risk
offering her 'this new movie so this
person if that movie doesn't do well
doesn't get fired you know I think it's
all I think we talked about that too
last time it's all fear-based
people don't want to be seen taking
risks because if that goes badly they
lose that
so I think you have to give them as much
of a reason to trust you with something
that they can defend when talking to
their bosses as possible and that means
make a feature I would after film school
urge everyone to not waste time making
short films long and short answer I
don't think that most people were
equipped to go make a $50,000 visual
effects driven short film that they're
going to take to film festivals and try
to get the attention of a major agency
to sign them to a studio picture that's
going to be a multi-million dollar event
film there are examples but I think
they're very few if you start
quantifying the number of people that
get to do that versus the number of
people that actually attempt it I think
at the end of the day you're better
served unless you happen to be a visual
effects genius and if you are more power
to you go do it but if you do not have
the capacity or the skills to do some of
that yourself spend the money in other
ways you can make a $50,000 feature film
instead of your $50,000 short visual
effects driven film that might enable
you to do something better that you
probably could monetize by selling it
yourself and put yourself in a better
position to advance your career I was
talking about that with a professor of
mine at UCLA who is with the correct
prediction bunny who is a veteran in a
hand and anyways like don't make a
feature once you you're out of him
school film school is a great place to
make shorts and I did a bunch of shorts
at UCLA to learn I was I was learning
like that but it's true that one advice
I would have is don't lose time on doing
shorts I mean there are so many people
there who are making films and killing
themselves directors that I think that
the right now times have changed and
it's not like it used to be with a
Spielberg Lucas who get famous because
of their shorts and get access to bigger
film because of their shorts nowadays I
mean we are
the time of digital cinema and getting
pretty usable camera is pretty cheap you
can even do it with your iPhone and so
it's all about people are going to judge
if you are able to hold a long time and
be able to make a true feature film so I
was like I don't want to make it short
anymore so let's do feature films
I think it's a good idea when it's time
for investor sometime you can just if
you don't have let's say a big
background of film that you did before
then it will suggest at least do a great
short film of maybe a scene or concept
why is something like whatever it like
it there's a term about it but it's like
maybe a 10 minute version how they film
something like that and then showcase
that to investors that's really gonna
tell them just your style directing
style and then you can say with if we
have more money than we can do this this
this this this but at least it's people
work with visuals so at least if you
show them something that's really really
gonna help a lot and then after that you
have to put a business plan because
they're all about numbers but for the
features in itself I guess it didn't for
me for example I do short film when I
have a concept that I want to work with
and like for ample I'm gonna do
something soon that I think I don't know
but I'm kind of sure that's gonna be
about my next video film so again
sometimes just always happy accidents
sometimes you try a new technique and
stuff like that but I will recommend
that if you're trying to get investors
and you don't have a lot of work then
yet to do a shortened version at least
to to help them visualize what you're
trying to do because it's easy to just
like it's gonna be amazing it's gonna be
great but please just show that you can
do something instead of just talking
well the first few short projects that I
did I was very fortunate to have a
couple of great publications around the
world write about them I was able to get
in some wonderful places and have people
watched them and because those two
things happened there was some respect
for the work that I was doing and it
attracted some attention from various
producers and I started getting some
phone calls about projects and when that
started happening I knew
that I had some options on the table
which allowed me to be a little
selective about the things that I choose
because like I was saying earlier I see
my career as a as a ladder or a
staircase that you're kind of building
up with each project and you're kind of
figuring out what direction you want to
take and the choices you make directly
impact which staircase you ascend I
think without directing the shorts that
I did those got some international
attention from various publications I
remember one day I woke up and followed
was featured and Spain's biggest horror
magazine there it's a horrible for
photographs which is their main film
publication and I thought that was wild
because I didn't send it to them they
just found it and when things like that
happened you start realizing that people
are watching your work and paying
attention to what you're doing and
without those experiences I wouldn't
have had the opportunity to direct
desires of the heart because I wouldn't
have had the experience or the attention
I loved interspersing them I mean I
probably I'm working on a short now that
is related to the same issue or a number
of shorts but I like you know I think
it's tough after a three to four year
halt to just you know I guess it's like
having kids or something where you know
you know how quickly do you sort of
delve into it again sometimes you wait
and sometimes you don't but I love the
genre of short film even there are more
platforms now for it and I I think you
know efficient filmic filmmaking can I
think a lot of documentaries are too
long nowadays and in some ways and and
not all need to be feature-length length
films so I I love the I just love the
genre as much as I love short stories
vs. novels so it's it's something I love
working with a lot of times if it's a
student filmmaker the first time film
they want to make it a feature but they
don't even know the steps of how to do
that but they want to make this they're
kind of not just calling card but more
of a you know a showpiece of what the
story could be you know whether it is
the you know first
it's the film or you know if it's almost
like the first act or just more this is
the kind of story they want to tell this
is what the short is but made the
feature version will just be an
extension of that whether you know like
that kind of thing so you get a lot a
lot of that where the films that we were
screening
I don't know percentage-wise but me
because there are a lot that are also
just short films or remain specifically
to be assured not to be a feature to
tell a certain story a certain way to be
a short film and I stand alone but there
are a lot of films that the intention is
still Kaling to turn this in the future
eventually you know or category of once
those are horror shorts the great they
essentially want to make those into
features and just finish the script and
just go ahead and shoot a feature film
of the film that they did like say the
can in the horror category for instance
you get a lot out with that with that
category and some people are already
have that in place you know they have
the script ready and then finally go out
there and meet people the festival - you
know hustle and make it happen and so
folks just that's their intention but
they haven't gotten the point where they
are ready to even shoot a feature but
you do see a lot of that plan is that
these films and going back to stuffing
something like this the festival a lot
of films we have are the this is the
first film and a journey for people you
know that are going on the time a
feature films and work in this business
and I'd make more movies this is not the
end-all be-all this is the beginning so
this is very early in the process of a
person's career and you know what that
majority of these films are you know the
filmmakers have feature film aspirations
for these these stories are there near
and dear to them but it's not all of
them obviously it's a certain percentage
of them that are that are that but do
you only see a certain amount of
filmmakers you talk to they have a real
plan in place already with the short to
feature like we've seen that a few times
like last year you did have a film that
we screen the feature year before we
screen is short and but at the same time
they were shooting the short already
having the feature film in mind and the
budget in place they're actually just
getting that they want to get that short
out there a little bit and they were
already had the plans they already had
financing for the feature it's something
you can show investors show people like
this is what we have this is what I can
do outside of just you know pitching
them with nothing you have something and
if you do have the star attached to this
star is talent that can help financing
in there
the film even better for that reason you
know if they're gonna see if they can
see that the persons in the film and you
can see the work and see what it is and
persons attached and literally in the
short you know that you know we've seen
that before and in our fest and you know
and we've seen that example and I think
that's definitely something that works
the strategy of releasing amateur free
online is really about other than it
being a long time since I've released a
film that I directed and just you know
sort of having that that that feeling of
my god good this thing is out there and
you know I feel like that is worth a lot
right there but but really the strategy
is reaching the sports world and the
basketball world you know this is a
story that I think hasn't been told
before I'm talking about the feature and
I think there's a lot of interest in hat
as far as you know there's an ongoing
suit against the NCAA from something
Makara about our should college athletes
be paid you know I think a lot people
don't know how young the recruiting has
gotten like a lot of basketball players
have gone through this themselves a lot
of hooks in the basketball world so the
reason that I released it free online
was to reach that world and we're going
to be we're gonna be releasing on
YouTube and making sort of a second a
second launch for the short to that end
releasing amateur online has been just
another example of sort of the community
and the networking making something
possible and hopefully you know at the
at the end of the day that's gonna be
what makes this this feature get made
not just the the crowdfunding and the
Kickstarter and the new film school
audience but also just filmmakers
talking to each other and helping each
other out is really that's really what
my side is all about and hopefully you
know at the end of the day manchild will
be a good example of that too
I think that there's so much room to
live and grow in this so that you know
film the films you make should
definitely be your learning experience I
remember when I did my first film my
pure joy it was a complete learning
experience because I had a seven
thousand dollar budget I was eighteen
years old nobody wanted to work with me
so I had to do every single job on the
film I was craft services I was I held
the boom I you know I did lighting I
edited it I literally like every job
imaginable I did on that film and I
think that's what really helped me grow
as a filmmaker it was my film school I
had to do everything I was a
three-person crew on that it was me a
makeup artist that I helped doing
special effects with and a DP who owned
the camera and so that was it so and we
we made a movie on a seven thousand
dollar budget the one thing we were able
to get very easily was actors to work
for free because everybody wants to act
so but after that it was you know it was
a learning curve and and I learned so
much from that film that when I look
back on it I'm like I should have never
you know released this but uh
miraculously got onto the best sellers
list on Amazon we were ranked number 32
and horror for a month and a half and I
put a lot of you know PR and marketing
behind it I sat there for days and days
because before I did that I did you know
PR and marketing when I was a kid for a
bunch of DJ's like you know big
electronic music artists that were
playing you know around the world and I
used to throw raves so I knew how to you
know market stuff so I I pushed the film
a bunch and it sold well and so I think
ultimately what's important for a
filmmaker is to learn from every single
project they do always try to raise the
budget always try to tell a good story
don't be so concerned about everything
being so perfect on your first one
because as long as you get the first one
done you can always do the next one you
know I wasn't going to
get picked to direct aliens or something
it wasn't that but I wasn't going to
happen and I started to think of her I
started to think independently I was
like well look I've got to demonstrate
that I know that I demonstrate that I
can make a feature film to myself and
anybody else so I can't wait on somebody
giving me a fee money for a feature film
so I got to figure out a way to do this
and he was like oh well that's because
so many people are like well you know
it's studio I'm only gonna make fifty
million dollar movies and I'm gonna
spend the next ten years in development
and then it's like I never had the
patience for that I was and I guess I
was a bit of a pessimist I was like look
I'm gonna have to do this somehow am I
on my own we're realists yeah or yeah
just be or yeah and I just was like okay
how do I do that well I don't have that
money but this guy did this guy had the
money at least a modicum of money right
on the credit card and he had the the
will
his name was his name was Mick wine-off
and and Mick was like I'm gonna do this
and I think he was suffering from the
same sort of fatigue that all of us he
had been coming as an actor he had been
trying to get parts and stuff and had
God had some success but he was getting
frustrated like this is going nowhere no
one's gonna give me a lead part so I
need to come up with a way where I can
get a lead part
well I'll produce a movie I'll pay for
it that'll guarantee me this lead part
and he had the strength and the he had
the smarts enough to put the thing
together he's the one who got Danny
Bonaduce but he still needed someone
like myself to write and direct it and
bring more cast and more crew and bring
that and so it was a good you know as a
classic collaboration he had these
resources but he needed this he needed
this from me and I needed someone to
bankroll my first feature so that's
that's how that happened no one was ever
gonna give me the opportunity I had to
take it so one of the first movies I
ever did out in LA of my own I got a
bunch of my friends together who were
still in college I had graduated year
early because I was ahead of a lot of
them because of the high school thing
and they had that summer and I knew what
my summer was like right after you
graduated sort of like what do I do now
there's not a whole lot of
commitments you have a lot of time most
people don't have a full time job yet
but sooner or later they're all gonna
get that or they're gonna go off and
start living their adult lives well I
saw a key opportunity to to get a lot of
my old moviemaking friends back together
and take that short period of time that
none of us would ever get back again and
try to do something with it
something that we would all be able to
benefit from and that would be that was
making a feature films my first film
that nobody knows about it's called
finger man dr. London in the Triangle
force that's actually my first feature
film although compound is being sort of
presented as my first my directorial
debut with finger man was actually my
first feature film and it was a major
collaborative effort with a lot of my
good friends from back in the day Chris
Cowen Dan Davidson Stephen Waller a
Steve Murray
Vonzell Carter Noah Applebaum James
Flynn like these are my really good
friends from back in the day that we all
came up making movies together
everybody's off doing their own thing
now for the most part and they're all
successful in their own right but we all
got together for that one little piece
of time we are going to make that and I
think you have to also recognize that
sometimes there are gonna be moments
where you don't ever get that
opportunity back like I'm so glad I did
that movie because I would never have a
lot of things that I have today because
of that movie and actually and one of
your questions was going to be about the
American night or the finger man on a
lot thing that legitimize me in a lot of
people's eyes and it got me a lot of
jobs and got me in a lot of doors that I
probably wouldn't be able to get into
otherwise even though it wasn't even
like a big deal really I mean I'll tell
you talk about that later but yeah
finger man was a huge learning
experience and I still watch it today
I'm still happy with that film I think I
was like one of the most fun times of my
was a good time well it also was one of
the most educational the sheer amount of
time it takes to take a feature film
from concept to asses sitting in front
of the screen watching it and you know
just as an example all guys creatures I
started writing in June of oh eight and
it was on store shelves through our
distributor in May of 2012 so that was
nearly a four year window that's me and
three other guys the figureheads on the
project worked tirelessly for no money
to make this thing happen and you know
had I had known that going into it how
much time and effort that would that
would take I might not have done it I
hope that's not the case I hope I still
would have done it but I I you know I
guess it's important to know that going
into it that it is a ridiculously long
road to get a feature film made and out
there and to do so you really need to
love the story that you're trying to
tell and and you know that is probably
of all these things the most important
component to have in place before you
walk into the process is to really give
a about telling the story because
there's no telling the number of
obstacles you have to overcome to make
that happen so don't make some shitty
film that you would want to sit in a
theater and watch make sure it's
something you care about because that is
going to be what carries you through
those really really shitty nights where
everything the sky is falling now go
make your thing
as far as the learning from your short
films
I think short films are a great place to
learn and grow when you're doing short
form and harnessing your abilities but
they're not going to get you that that
big-budget feature they're not going to
get you you know a feature what what you
need to do is maybe hone your craft in
the short films however you want and and
just play I was making short films since
I was you know 6 years old and you know
I I did tons of short films I used to
turn in short films my teachers hated me
and in middle school in high school
instead of doing book reports I would
turn in a short film on why I didn't
want to do the book report so you know
always make short films and learn and
grow from that but really harness your
abilities from your features and and use
those features as stepping stones for
the next feature and as long as you're
going up in some way be it budget or
cast or just making a better movie on
each on each go around you're doing
great because at the end of the day if
you're not if you're not learning and
you're improving and you're not
improving then it's time to quit because
if you haven't learned something from
what you do each time then you have
nothing left to learn and everybody has
something left to learn so if you think
you don't stop doing it everyone's
always waiting for someone to give them
to allow them to believe in an idea and
to give them a green light and go let go
but no one will you know so if you don't
just go and I think that's what I meant
by always be shooting don't wait for
someone else to give you the green light
or the money or the support because it
99% won't be there and the people that
are not shooting are the people that
have been developing the same script for
10 years and they're waiting for
financing for 20 mil for someone to give
them 20 million dollars that's not going
to happen you know I think the people
that are shooting other people that grab
the video camera and said I'm going to
do this quirky little thing now and see
how it turns out and then they show to
someone who sees something in it and
then you go from there but you
need to be doing it rather than waiting
and hoping that someone will allow you
to do it and we have all the tools today
right there's no excuse anymore to to
wait because we just don't need the same
resources that we needed 20 years ago or
something
everyone can shoot a movie on their
iPhone like tangerine there isn't such a
thing as a maximum you should spend on a
short film but I think there's a maximum
you should spend as to what you can
afford and as to what your story needs
to serve it well I think that when
you're making a short or even a micro
budget feature for that matter whatever
it is you always need to treat your
budget as what is the lowest amount I
can make this film for that will best
serve the story and not for my attempt
to make it the best I can and that
doesn't matter what you're trying to
make but whatever it is make sure you
can afford it because say for example
you do spend ten thousand dollars on
that short film you've made the short
film but that's not the end of your
expenses is it now you have Film
Festival submissions say you get into
some festivals you probably want to go
to those festivals to network to meet
other producers to meet other filmmakers
to do some press for it to do the things
that are going to give your movie
attention how much money did you budget
for that did you not budget money for it
now you have another couple thousand
that you've added to your total budget
those are things that you have to ask
yourself at the onset and if you only
have ten thousand dollars to make the
film that isn't just production that's
all of those other fees that come with
it
so you really have to think what is the
lowest amount I can tell this story
effectively at so I can enable myself to
get to my next goal and those are all
factors that any filmmaker that takes
their career seriously should consider
now if you're just doing this amateur if
you just want to make films because you
like doing it as a hobby you don't need
to worry with all that but if you want
to be a professional filmmaker if you
want to be a professional writer
director actor those are factors you
absolutely have to account
having no parameters I think is harder
than having some like or limitations
let's look at them as limitations if
somebody says you can make anything you
want I don't care what the subject
matter is and the sky's the limit for
the budget I think you're gonna have a
harder time I mean unless yes you may
we're all nursing these epics that we
want to make but if someone says you can
have anything you want or it's like one
of those questions like you you just won
that blotter it you just want a hundred
million dollars what are you gonna buy
it's almost like you're but if somebody
says no you have to do this within this
particular box I think it those walls
which can be walls or limitations
sometimes are good things because you
now have an arena within which to work
and it's not just the entire universe
it's this so shooting on video
having somebody get killed every five
pages or whatever those things were
nudity all those and you know all those
things were like okay well now I had
those are the elements that I have to
deal with and it made it a little bit
easier for me to come up with the with
the story
whenever I'm sitting at someone who's
sort of standing between where they are
now and and and and their first film or
their first passion project I don't want
to limit it just to films because for a
lot of people it's it's it maybe it's
writing the first screenplay maybe it's
producing their first television pilot
or any number of sort of ambitious
projects not just feature-length films
there's that expression go big or go
home I think you should go small or go
home on your first project do something
that that is not so ambitious that
you're not going to make it to the
finish line because I the only thing
worse than a film that's not you know
that's maybe not as successful as the
filmmaker hoped is a film that doesn't
get finished I mean that's just the
thought of that like rips my heart out
you know you got to film the TAF way
done and then you walk away from it or a
screenplay that's 2/3 of the way done
and they didn't quite finish for
whatever reason I mean that's if you're
gonna really take that leap do something
that you
no you have the ability to finish you
either you need to you need to have a
great story that you love that you're in
love with you need to have the technical
chops to see it through to the end you
need partners if you don't have all the
funding or all the pieces that are
important make sure you have them and
maybe more important most importantly is
you need friends and colleagues who are
willing to look at early cuts or read
early versions of a screenplay and tell
you if it's any good or not I mean
that's really important we had all those
things when we made our first film and
probably more important than anything my
brother and my best friend encouraged us
to take that leap and said look we have
a little bit of money we can lend you
some money to get the ball rolling which
they did and and and that was
tremendously helpful we paid him back
I wrote mine I broke my brother a check
for $100,000 equity sold wordplay which
really felt great and and I think the
last thing I mean the one other thing I
would I would encourage people to do is
to really constrain themselves give
yourself a time limit
give yourself some deadlines and work
within them so when we started wordplay
the star of that film is a man named
Will Shortz who's the editor of the New
York Times crossword puzzle and we we
pitched our idea to him I just I called
the New York Times and left him a
voicemail and he called me back that was
the beginning of that film but I told
him what we had in mind and he said to
me he said well he said this sounds
really fun and I I just want to tell you
there's a team that's three or four
years into making this very same sort of
project but they're not done yet
and I don't know haven't heard from them
in a while
they are on this he said so the one
thing I would ask you is if you're gonna
make this movie I'd like it to be done
in a year because then you know it's not
too much work on him and we'll create
some momentum and we won't stop till we
finish it a year after we had that
conversation we were together at
Sundance with the film and and that's
really important when I hear that a film
is six or seven or eight years in the
making
unless it's hoop dreams or Ken Burns's
the civil war or something less in an
epic film Sherman's march sure if it's
something that's just a giant film that
needs all that time great more power to
you most films are not like that and
once you lose that momentum it's really
hard to get it back it's like going on a
road trip and stopping every 10 miles I
mean eventually you're just gonna turn
around and go back